if committee is right here I won't go
through the ultra line rigmarole because
everyone who's been never born knows
they're rough but basically he will
present the public a few of us in the
public can ask them questions and then
we'll leave them to his committee and
then he'll be excused from the committee
and they'll decide whether he
successfully defended his thesis or not
so Sean is a student in the BC B tract
or major as we call it now in the
program he received his Bachelor of
Science degree in electrical engineering
from Portland State and also attended a
graduate program in a very large scale
integration design also Portland State
he has worked in the electronics
industry over 25 years and his area of
research focuses on machine learning and
computer image analysis of a prostate
cancer MRI data set so we will hear
about that what it's bill and thank you
for coming Mike my thesis defense on
computer aided diagnosis of prostate
cancer using multi parametric MRI and
evaluation of feature extraction and
classification first I'd like to go
through an introduction and background
on prostate cancer and diagnosis methods
so prostate cancer prevalence in the
United States the NIH and 2018
projector that prostate cancer will be
the third highest in the number of new
cases behind the lung cancer and breast
cancer and so as we can see prostate
cancer amounts to almost 10% of all the
new cases projected in 2018 and it
accounts for almost five percent of all
cancer related deaths prostate cancer if
diagnosed and treated early does have a
five-year survival rate of 98% and this
is when the prostate cancer is localized
to the prostate gland anyway and not
metastasize to other parts of the body
so current prostate cancer diagnosis
methods first we start out with prostate
cancer screening which has two forms a
prostate specific antigen blood test and
a digital rectal exam given an elevated
PSA or GRE abnormalities are found the
patient is then undergoes a transexual
ultrasound guided biopsy if this proves
an inconclusive biopsy then the patient
is referred to a magnetic resonance
imaging guided in bore biopsy it should
be noted that all 78 patients in this
dataset have undergone this series where
their trust biopsies were inconclusive
and then they were referred to the
magnetic resonance in bore guided biopsy
so what is a magnetic resonance in bore
guided biopsy first human image analysis
from a pathologist decides if a biopsy
has one needed and determines the region
of interest to guide that biopsy this
method has an improved accuracy over the
trust biopsy method and it also provides
ground truth for computer image analysis
so studies such as mine however
possibility of over biopsy is due to
human visual limitations and these
limitations are humans ability to detect
subtle pattern differences and intensity
variations in an image so what is multi
parametric MRI and I'll give an example
of multiple MRI modalities used here at
OHSU for prostate cancer diagnosis and
the first is an anatomical t2-weighted
image this type of image looks at the
water content in specific tissues so it
gives a spatial resolution of different
tissues and a spatial resolution of
healthy tissue versus any malignant
tissue this method is then added with
two functional MRI image types the first
is diffusion weighted image and this
type of image looks at a water molecule
diffusion through tissue and through
cells and from a diffusion weighted
image and the parent diffusion
coefficient map is calculated and the
second type of functional MRI image used
is dynamic contrast enhancement and this
is where a contrast is introduced to the
patient intravenously and it measures
blood flow through various tissues and
through healthy tissue and cancerous
tissue so ADC Maps calculated from the
diffusion weighted image are the new
game-changer used by radiologists and in
computer image analysis so these are
moved just a step forward using these
apparent diffusion coefficient maps now
from literature studies in prostate
cancer Multi parametric computer image
analysis used predominantly t2-weighted
and
see maps or a combination of t2 weighted
imaging ADC maps and DCE
for their multi parametric features I've
highlighted in red here the two
modalities that I'm using in the data
set which are teaching weighted an ADC
here we go Hsu did take dynamic contrast
images however the physician that
provided this dataset thought that the
DCE images didn't land any more
information than was already present in
the t2-weighted and ADC maps and that's
why we only have the two in this data
soon so my project definite definition
the overall goal is to build an
algorithm the best identify the lignin
of an ID patients with the potential of
reducing over biopsy and ultimately
enabling in silicon via obscene so in
silico biopsy would be something we
could achieve one day where the imaging
alone could tell us if the patient was
malignant and benign and when the
patient would not have to go through an
invasive needle biopsy a specific aim of
this project is to evaluate the
feasibility of machine learning methods
based on feature extraction from the
images and classification for
differentiating benign and malignant
prostate cancer tumors in multi
parametric MOR
and so the materials and methods that I
used in this study first the image
dataset used in the study so I have
processed images from 78 patients that
were collected here at OHSU
and the table shows the breakdown
between malignant and benign patients so
as you can see we have 55 malignant
patients with a total of 155 associated
images have 23 benign patients with a
total of 64 associated images for a
total of 78 patients of 219 images one
thing important to notice here is the
unbalanced nature of the dataset I have
a lot more benign or malignant patients
than I do than our inpatients and the
two right-hand columns show that I have
images from both the peripheral zone and
the transition zone of the prostate
gland so we have a robust data set to
look at two different areas and two
different and the way they look
differently to MRI images to point out
regions of interest or our allies have
been identified by a radiologist for
these images MRI Emboar guided biopsy
was used to provide the ground truth for
the malignant versus benign classes
malignant patients these patients have a
Gleason score of greater than or equal
to six and so this is a score of 6
through 10 and what this means is the
pathologist in assessing the cells saw
that the cells were high-grade
aggressive and fast-growing and thus
likely to spread to other areas of the
prostate gland the benign patients in
the status that have no Gleason score so
although the cells look abnormal they
look closer to the healthy cells than to
in the malignant they're thought to be
slow growing and non aggressive and once
again only images that look suspicious
for cancer
are included in the patient image
dataset so in the center column we can
see that malignant patients have
anywhere between 1 and 8 images per
patient and the benign have anywhere
between 1 and 6 images per patient now
this is dependent on the ROI that was
identified by the radiologist so some
some regions of interest are small or
some of the larger and so even though
the patients have the same number of
images taken very few will show the
region of interest and so here malignant
and benign examples of the t2-weighted
and the ABC map images teach awaited on
the top ADC map on the bottom one you
can tell the difference in how these
images work on the computer screen the
red arrows indicate where suspicious
areas looked to the radiologist and as
you can tell it's a little at least for
me easier to see on the ADC maps where
these regions would be versus the
t2-weighted and so here's the exact same
images the red outlines show what the
radiologist actually outlined as a
region of interest and these outlined
areas will be used to guide the biopsy
area ok so the algorithm flowchart that
I used as mentioned I'm using
t2-weighted images and a DC map images
in this dataset these are first run
through the first step which is image
pre-processing the image pre-processing
step will give us t2-weighted and ADC
extracted are a liar is and it's from
these extract that I rely errors will
run through a second step of t texture
feature extraction and the texture
feature extraction will yield and
texture feature vectors representing
these
of interest they'll run through a third
step which is dimensionality reduction
and the purpose here is to reduce the
larger text or feature vector to a
reduced texture feature vector then we
go into a fourth step you using various
classifiers to classify malignant and
benign images from the results of the
classification as you can see in the top
right graph a receiver operating
characteristic curve is generated from
the classification results and an area
under this curve is calculated it's this
area under the curve that will be used
as the metric that will judge
classification accuracy so the first
step image pre-processing denoising I've
used three denoising methods the first
is a median kernel method and this is
simply a 3x3 pixel centered on the pixel
of interest that is convolve de cross
all pixels in the image and finds a
median value or rounded out this is a
very popular method in image analysis as
it tends to remove random noise with
less blurring of the underlying image
than do other linear smoothing filters
the second is a variational auto encoder
and the third is a convolutional auto
encoder I also use an auto encoder for a
dimensionality reduction so at this
point I'd like to take a few moments to
explain auto encoder as shown on the
bottom here the auto encoder is a neural
network has built up of two segments the
encoder section and the decoder section
and so essentially we're taking a input
vector of values and we're encoding
those to a smaller vector which we call
the latent layer this latent layer is
them
decoded back to an output layer that
matches the input layer features and
it's from this we can frame this neural
network to come up with a latent layer
that best represents that input layer of
features so in image and now in image
analysis use these autoencoders have
shown use in image compression down to a
smaller lay layer but they've also shown
good use in image denoising and that's
why i've included several types here in
the variational auto encode or the image
is broken into one long vector of pixel
intensity values that are run through
the auto encoder and the convolutional
auto encoder the 2d images taken
involved with several filters to perform
the auto encoding function so step two
texture feature extraction so the
features in the study have been
extracted from two-dimensional ry images
as shown in the top picture so from that
ry outlined we produce at extra feature
vector I've used five methods the first
is gray level Corcoran's matrix
the second is grade level size zone
matrix and the third is a grade level
run length matrix all three of these
methods will produce a matrix from the
extracted features of the ROI and then
calculate second order statistics from
that matrix to give us our texture
feature vector the fourth is a local
binary pattern where we round each pixel
a binary pattern is calculated and this
is more of a histogram based method
counting up the different patterns that
we've extracted and the fifth is a multi
resolution alfredo dimension method and
what this entails is using wavelet
decomposition of the image and from the
wave of decomposition of the image the
fractal dimensions are calculated uses
whether
called a box counting method so the
extracted features for both the
t2-weighted an ADC modalities so here
I'm showing the extraction feature
methods and the number of features we
get from them
so first the co-occurrence matrix it
will give us 13 features per direction
for a total of 52 features for all for
rotational directions of the image GL CM
is also important please an averaging of
the four directions to give us 13
features the grade level size own matrix
produces 12 features in our vector the
grade level run length matrix will give
12 features per direction for a total of
48 features for the for rotational
directions and averaging is also applied
here of from the 4 directions to give a
total of 12 the local binary pattern
gives 36 rotationally invariant features
the fractal dimension method gives 4
features per direction for a total of 16
once again for the 4 directions and also
applies averaging to yield 4 features so
what we want to notice here is there's a
total of 30 feature vectors that were
extracted for each modality it's from
these 30 features for each modality that
then are combined to produce the
features for our multidimensionality
features step three dimensionality
reduction and so the goal of
dimensionality reduction is to find the
best subset of features that best
correlate to the benign and malignant
classes in order to reduce classifier
over fit
which improves classification accuracy
and so here I've used three methods
first is minimum redundancy maximum
relevance this has been shown to be used
extensively in prostate cancer image
analysis studies with great effect and
so I've included it here
the second is elastic mat this is
popular machine learning and pioneered
by Trevor Hass DJ mount Stanford it's
used also used in many prostate cancer
analysis studies and so I've used it
here as well and the third is the auto
encoder and so this auto encoder is
fully connected neural network it's
commonly used in machine learning
not so much in prostate cancer image
analysis so here I wish to assess its
usefulness in prostate cancer image Al's
against the other two widely used
methods muscle step for classification
so here I've used four different
classifiers first is support vector
machine this has been shown again to be
used extensively and prostate cancer
image analysis studies this does well at
separating various data class
distributions the random forests again
used extensively in prostate cancer
image analysis random force do well with
noisy datasets which I mean they may
very well have here the third is the
logistic regression logistic regression
is tied in with elastic map so elastic
net is the penalty term on the input
variables that are then applied to the
logistic regression classifier and
fourth is an ensemble of classifiers so
in looking at the results that I got
from the individual classifiers I showed
a large variance and classification
error and that lends well to an ensemble
of classifiers method
and step 5
now we must evaluate the models I used a
cable cross validation method where the
K equals 10 and so to illustrate that
we'll look at the table on the left and
so what this entails is breaking up the
data set into ten subsets over folds and
then one fold is held out for testing
while the other folds are used for
training now if we remember back the
malignant and benign data set was quite
unbalanced so here I was able to
separate the malignant portion of the
data set into ten subsets but in order
to balance each fold between malignant
or benign images I could only break up
the benign images into five subsets so
here I had to reuse the benign one
through benign five in the last five
fold in order to balance these data sets
out now however to avoid training bias
the fold whose benign data matches the
selected test fold is left out of the
training set and as an example if I hold
out fold one for testing I also have to
hold up fold six and not use it for
training and the reason is both of those
folds contain the benign learn subset so
if I train with the Medaille in one
subset and I test whether I'm gonna bias
myself toward very good benign
predictions because I've already trained
with those and so this essentially turns
this into a nine-fold cross-validation
where I hold one for testing eight for
training and the other ones held out not
used so as I mentioned before the model
evaluation metric for classification
accuracy is the area under the curve and
so ROC curves are calculated for all Tam
test folds that we go through here on
the right I've shown an example and I've
cut it down just to three ROC curves
just for clarity so I don't mess
you can see each one has a different
color for a different fold and an AEC so
the area under these curves is
calculated for all of each auto City
from the fold and so the final
evaluation metric is a mean of all Tana
uses and I've also represented those
with a plus or minus one standard
deviation in the following result and so
the models used in this study so a model
consists of a dimensionality reduction
method and a classifier and so you can
see I've got mr mr and svm mr mr random
forests autoencoder an SVM auto-encoder
and random forests so here we will be
able to tell using the same classifiers
with a different width dimensionality
reduction methods we can judge does mr
mr autoencoder per for better or worse
we can get a judgment between those two
in using the same classifiers number 5
elastic map as I mentioned it goes right
along with logistic regression and then
a sixth ensemble of classifiers that was
used and I took the five classifiers
individual classifiers I call them and
then take a majority vote from all the
individual models to get the final
classification okay
and now results so first the image
denoising in step one shows the VA e
underperforms and so I've used a mean
squared error which is used to compare D
noised image deviation from the original
image so the lower the number the less
deviation from the D noise to the
original image and this table shows an
average MSE for all of the t2-weighted
images and all of the ADC images I had
available I've hi
didn't read that the VA II vastly
underperformed the colonel or the CIA
method so because VA II shows a much
greater differences from the original
image than the colonel or CIE methods it
was not used in assessing model
performance using denoise images and
here's kind of a visual example of what
we're talking about where the VA II
removes image pattern information
so besides removing noise as we want it
it's removing pattern information that I
need to extract from these features to
better predict the classification and so
here I've shown t2 a 2d noise images and
ADC images against the original image
and so what we can see I highlighted in
red if you look at the original the
kernel or the CAE the dark and light
pattern information is preserved with
the colonel and the CAE methods however
is not preserved in the VA images this
table shows just the MSE for these
particular regions of interest examples
and again vastly underperformed what we
get for colonel or CAE so here's one key
result from the study Multi parametric
images outperform individual t2 later
than ADC images so I've listed for the
five models on the left hand side I've
listed the best t2-weighted AUC and the
best ADC AUC for these models and I've
also listed the best parametric AUC for
these models I've highlighted D's in
bold because for every model the
t2-weighted image or the multi
parametric images outperform t2-weighted
or a you see now we can get some
information from this table the first is
the mr-mrs preferred over the auto
encoder so if you look at the first four
rows using the same
classifiers that the auto-encoder
underperforms what the mrr mrr produces
also in general neither the t2-weighted
nor a DC stand out for classification
performance that may be with the
exception of the second row mr mr and
random forests where a DC does seem to
perform better but in general a DC and
t2-weighted or not outperforming each
other and also now from looking at all
the numbers the multi parametric
features account for the at least at the
top to AC scores for all models here
I've just shown the table but at least
the top two for all models so the
conclusion I draw here is I recommend
using multi parametric features over the
individual t2-weighted or ABC features
now we can find a recommended multi
parametric feature and model I've
highlighted this with the red arrow over
on the left hand side so what we can see
is based on our AUC metric that the mrr
mrr and random forest model performs
best over the other five models and the
best feature is a t2-weighted LBP bin
size one combined with an ADC LBP a bin
size three i've also here shown various
other metrics such as sensitivity which
is the ability to correctly predict the
malignant class the specificity the
ability to correctly project to the
benign class and positive and negative
predicts your vowed prediction values
which basically say if this test says
your malignant for example then that's
the probability that you truly are
malignant and have a limb misclassified
one other thing we can notice is the
makeup of the features as we saw with
our best feature the
a combination of t2-weighted an ADC with
a different feature times if you look at
mr mr and svm this was a DC and LBP but
they were both in size 1 and here is 3
features that are all multi parametric
so these have a DC and LBP a DC MLBPA DC
and LBP and they were the best so
there's a myriad of different ways of
the multi parametric features being
combined or they give us the best so
what can we get from this based on the a
you sees for the mr NMR and random
forest model is my recommended image
level model and if we notice that LBP is
totally or partially involved in the 5
models top a you see scores and so as
shown in column 2 so thus my
recommendation for multi parametric
feature extraction method is LBP so
let's look at the multi parametric
feature model comparisons without having
to look at all these numbers I think
this graph is a little better to show
all the various models note that you had
an ideal best model that all the bars
for that model would be up at 1 or close
to 1 and so as we see mrr mrr in the
random forest over here on a you see is
the best de you see however for
sensitivity it is the third best even
though it has the highest AUC and it
does show a trade-off between
sensitivity and specificity similar for
the dark blue mrr mrr and SVM is the
second best AUC score but it has the
best sensitivity score and also shows
that trade-off between sensitivity and
specificity so we're predicting better
on malignant at mistake and predicting
benign elastic map somewhat shows the
opposite where it is the lowest
malignant predictor in specificity and
since
but it's the best in specificity so what
do we take away from this each marble
shows different strengths and that's why
if these lend themselves to an ensemble
of classifiers so we can exploit the
best strengths or try to exploit the
best strengths of all models so here we
show ensemble of classifiers is the best
model so the same graph but I've added
ensemble in the black bars and as you
can see on the AUC score it has the best
score and in fact shown in the red
arrows that the ensemble model performs
the best or toward the table
four five four of the five performance
metrics with specificity being the one
that's left out so what we can see here
is that the ensemble had an AC 0.77 3
which showed improvement over the
individual model mrr mrr in random
forests with an AUC 0.75 4 so the
overall conclusion is that the ensemble
is the best image classification model
so let's go back to the original and D
noised image model results here I've
shown along the x-axis the different
model types and the AUC with the
original image in blue the kernel method
D noised image in red and the caed
noised image in green and here we show
the AUC plus or minus at standard
deviation and so what we see here is
based on the majority which is three of
the five highest au C's course the
original image our wise were selected
for model evaluation we didn't need the
D noise damages so all of the results
that I've shown previously we're on the
original images on T noise damages I say
however I recommend that if data set
denoising is performed if one wants to
compare their the noise the image verse
the original images that you should use
the CAE denoising method as it performed
better than the kernel method okay
we found the image level model we found
our best image level model so now
determining a patient diagnosis model
let's move this into the clinic what is
a useful diagnostic decision support
model in a clinical setting and so what
we have to do is imply the image level
model to the patient level so we're
going from image classification to
patient diagnosis and so I've said the
goal of the best model as the model with
zero or the lowest number of
misdiagnosed malignant patients and I'll
reiterate here that reducing
misdiagnosed malignant patients is
paramount I'd rather send the patient in
that's benign for over biopsy to let a
patient walk out the door that is
malignant with an aggressive cancer that
goes untreated and so I've said a
patient level model assessment criteria
and that is if one or more images in the
patient's data set is classified as
malignant then that patient is
classified or diagnosed as malignant and
so here we'll see patient diagnosed
results using adjusted malignant
threshold so we could saw up here the
malignant threshold probabilities I've
used point five which is the standard
the criteria if your point five it above
your malignant point five below your
benign and I've also adjusted the
threshold to say that if your above
point for your malignant and below that
benign so this just builds a little
insurance and if you will to say well if
you're close to being malignant we're
gonna count you as malignant so in the
table I basically show in the black the
point five malignant threshold
probabilities and the green the
the point for malignant probabilities as
we see two models now appear with the
shifted point four and that's mrr mrr
and SVM and auto-encoder an SVM they
both have zero malignant patients
misdiagnosed malignant patient's which
meets our goal and as you see at 0.5 no
model have a zero so just a slight shift
got us to models also notice that the
ensemble model as we pointed out was our
best image level model but even with
shifted it still has one misdiagnosed
malignant patient so these don't they're
the best image level model does not
necessarily correlate to the best
patient diagnosis model using the
criteria that I said so although
malignant or mrr mrr and SVM an
autoencoder an SVM have zero illness
diagnosed patients as shown in the red
the SVM has a better benign patient
diagnosis so as we can see here's the
truly benign diagnosed pages is 8 and
the truly benign diagnosed pages is 4 so
in the M RN SVM we we traded one more
malignant accuracy for one less benign
accuracy but we're still out of the 23
patients getting eight properly
diagnosed denies so my conclusion is
based on that that mrr mrr and SVM is
the base and best patient level
diagnosis model so we would recommend in
the clinic so some discussions um we'll
discuss a little bit of the previous
results first conclusions so basically I
have demonstrated an algorithm to enable
computer image analysis of benign and
malignant cancer patients that are shown
to work fairly well demonstrated that
multiplayer maps rick MRI is better
classification accuracy than t2 weighted
or ADC alone and I've introduced to the
best of my knowledge the concept of
ensemble
classifiers to multi parametric prostate
cancer image analysis and that ensemble
method was shown to be better than any
individual model at the image level and
so for this particular data set that I
have take your small data set that I
have here from OHSU I have found that
the optimum patient level clinical
diagnosis support model is mrr mrr
using an SVM classifier with the
polynomial kernel and the optimum
feature extraction method is LDP using a
BEM size of 1 so I'd like to talk a
little intro tumor heterogeneity and
image to how that relates to image
diversity this is also known as genetic
heterogeneity which is defined as an
uneven stratification of cell subgroups
in a tumor and so this is based on that
in cancerous cells in the tumor do not
all grow at the same rate and so what
I've done is taken an ROI image from an
ADC map and converted it to color just
so it's easier to see and six image
slices would be used to indicate the
biopsy area to find that other line so
if you could think of these images
showed the color is the region of
interest that was suspicious and the
white area around it is healthy prostate
vision so as you can see image 1 image 3
image 6 they don't cut through very much
if any malignant tissue whereas image 2
4 and 5 do cut through the malignant
tissue so now we have images in a single
ROI that show benign and malignant
tendencies so heterogeneity is a cause
of malignant patient image miss
classification that would be a
limitation to the study and here's why
in this study all patient image slices
are labelled based on biopsy results the
images are not Coral
to the biopsy area the images just find
the ROI the biopsy tells if the patient
isn't malignant or benign so we could
have as an image a a likely benign image
but it's mislabeled as malignant because
it is in this patient stage stack image
B shows a low malignant area but most of
it looking benign and this may be
classified as benign again it's labeled
as malignant but it may be classified as
benign and then see highly malignant
area classified properly as benign so
you can say here's why I came up with
one or more images in a patient set if
it was malignant the patient would be
malignant
because this would tell us the patient
was truly malignant and that's backed up
by the biopsy what does this mean well
we're gonna get confusion this these
images labeled as malignant but they
look like the nine they're gonna cause
no ways in our data set and that's gonna
confuse our classifier because you're
gonna have similar extracted features
but two different labels I've also
looked at correlations so I've looked
the first correlation I looked at was
due misclassified images have any
correlation in the image stack for a
patient meaning have a specific area of
the region of interest in the prostate
gland and the answer is no they have no
correlation I would sit the ROI sighs
did our life size have any matter and
there's no correlation to ROI size to
misclassified malignant or benign images
and the third thing I looked at was do
they if you remember we have
transitional zone and peripherals own
images do they correlate to either of
these two zones because different MRIs
pick up different veins and different
zones and the answer is no there was no
correlation
between misclassifying so as that was a
possible limitation of the study other
study limitations so we have a small
training set for classifiers as anyone
who's ever done machine learning or even
looked at data for date is better and
with and that gives you a more robust
data set and a larger data set also will
negate the effect of any of these
outliers that we may say second we saw
an unbalanced data set between malignant
and benign patient samples it'll be nice
to have a benign data set that was more
robust I duplicated the same benign
patients which didn't give me any better
variation in the types of benign
patients and ideally 3d images would be
preferred to the 2d images used in this
study because 3d images give more
information between the 2d slices these
these slices were based on 3 millimeter
slices so that we've lost on 2d images
any information in between these so
future directions obtain a larger
patient data set while I was working on
this study was 78 patients dr. Coakley
has told me that we have over 200
patients now for the data set so if we
redid this study we may have we will
improve and once again 3d images are
over 2d images if we can collect a large
enough data set of 3d images then we
could improve this study so at this
point I will wrap up with
acknowledgments first my thesis
committee
juegos song my thesis adviser ted Lieu
Tara's chairman of the committee and the
Gion C Bowl also on the committee and
key contributors dr. Fergus Coakley he
provided the data for us for this image
and also our Sharma mckerrod II who was
instrumental in working with the
radiologist to basically correlate this
dataset both the images and the are wise
and getting them into a format where I
could easily use these and start working
through my algorithm that's nice study
very very interesting so it seems that
there would be two ways two sources of
error basically so one what one is your
machine learning algorithm
you know misclassifies thing it seems to
have another possible source of error
would be that the image findings don't
perfectly correspond to the biopsy
findings and trying to formulate this
into a question but you know I guess how
much do we know about that just in terms
of how good because it just may be that
if there's not a absolutely perfect
correspondence between what's in the
image and what's seen under the
microscope
how does that impact your results it
would definitely I'll preface it by I
wrote paper for one of my classes on
radio genomics which was the mating or
mapping of imaging to genomic studies
and that required that you knew what
part of the biopsy was linked with what
image then you could go look sequence
find out over expression under
expression and tie that into an image
with the hope that the image
wouldn't tell you what that the genetics
if this was over under expressed and the
key on that it's a new field and
basically all the papers I read said
well if we can do this but to date I
don't think that I've ever read that
anyone could Acuras accurately look at
that certainly if you could find that
the the biopsy from that slide and match
it to that image we could get rid of one
of the limitations of the heterogeneity
mm-hmm I really think so let me you know
maybe yes one more question um so I I
like the clinical correlation that you
did because I can have a clinical
perspective on things and you know this
notion of minimizing missing malignant
diagnoses I think is a good one in
essence that becomes like a screening
test
you know we commonly do screening test
for cancer and when you do a screening
test you want something that's a hundred
percent well as close to a hundred
percent sensitive as you can get because
you'll there always be some kind of
follow-up what you don't want to have
happen is to miss something in the
screening you know because then that
patient will think that they're you know
they don't have the disease and and
you'll never see them back so wouldn't
it be that the models with the highest
sensitivity would lead to the lowest
rate of miss missing a malignant
diagnosis yeah and yes I went back
through I could go back if you actually
looked and saw that for the individual
model or even the ensemble model who had
better age D scores dad did the SVM plus
mrr mrr which turned out to be the best
patient diagnosis model if you look at
those numbers on that charge that the
SVM the one we came up with for patient
level did have the highest 0.88 okay
sensitivity the restaurant of 24 for the
one point eight for the mrr mrr random
forest so that won't that didn't I write
into it
thanks John so I have a question about
the the size of the ROI the correlation
I didn't quite catch is what that
correlation is you see you're saying
it's not correlated when Fergus just
emailed us couple days ago saying we
should consider size as a informative
future which is not considered here
because over here we're all using
texture features so to the MIS
classification yeah no it's not so I
went through and I do have the areas and
I worried about some of the extraction
methods because I go through and I look
and I say well okay like LBP for
instance right I'm making a histogram of
those and if I have a smaller size
obviously my histogram is gonna be very
small even though it's malignant or
benign compared to another one that has
a larger size and has more of that
particular pattern and so I worried
about that I said I said okay let me
look at size because it'll be P seems to
be my best thing could I make it better
by you know looking at the size and that
was not the case so when I went through
every so I made a spreadsheet of here's
the a you sees here's all the metrics
here's the sizes there's the zone there
and here's the location in the image
stack now that's given that the image
stack was preserved throughout the
process and so that number one was
toward maybe the you know pace of the
prostate gland and
and down the line and I didn't see that
was one of the first things I thought of
a long time ago as I said well what
about the size because some of the sizes
of these you know you can even think of
it maybe as the reason of inch like an
egg and if you just chop the top of that
angle it's gonna be a small size and in
the middle it's gonna be a much larger
size and I said is that throwing things
off and both of the legs and Anthony and
misclassifications didn't show any
correlation to the misclassified images
and I expected I thought that was gonna
be the low-hanging fruit and I was gonna
make sure I was leave anything under an
Archon and I talked about this we were
thinking cuz I spoke about that with her
I said well maybe we can just say okay
we can leave out in a patient's in a
sense we're not leaving any patients out
but in their set we could just leave out
a small Lorelei under a certain area but
what did we found no correlation which
was interesting
thanks mom thank you
[Applause]
[Music]